there's something called the arrival
fallacy and the arrival fallacy is the
belief if only I could get that job then
I would be happy once I take that
vacation then I will be happy and when
you usually when you reach that
destination it doesn't bring this big
bang of happiness that you expect but I
do think that there's something about
happiness where you feel like you're
always you're always reaching out for it
and one of the positive ways to address
this is is what I call an atmosphere of
growth people feel happier when they
feel like they're progressing when they
feel like something in their life is
growing or getting better one of the
ways you see this is that people have a
very strong preference to get raises and
in fact it's studies show that they will
choose to make less money overall in
order to be paid in a structure that is
big where they get paid more and more
over time rather than get paid less over
time even if they would make more money
if they took that second route which
doesn't make sense from an economic
standpoint but it makes a lot of sense
if you understand that people want this
this atmosphere of growth in their life
but it doesn't have to be only money it
could be something like learning to do
something new learning French learning
Photoshop making something better
cleaning out your garage fixing things
that don't work teaching somebody
something helping your child learn is
one of the thrills of being a parent
training your dog helping something grow
planting a garden gaining new skills
anything like this where you feel like
you see that you feel this atmosphere of
growth it's a wonderful engine of
happiness and it's something that's
available to people even when maybe they
feel like other parts of their lives are
out of control aren't working if they
can find some place in their life where
something's getting better where they
feel like something's improving in some
way they're growing that's going to help
them feel happier